hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich spiele heute endlich mal
wieder sketchfull mit der Luke Crew ich
habe hier gerade schon einen privaten
Raum mit Mitgliedern der lukshow
erstellt und ich würde sagen wir starten
die Runde dann noch einfach mal Runde
Nummer eins geht los ich muss sogar
direkt Zeichnen von daher nehme ich das
einfachste was es gibt und zwar einen
Becher wir zeichnen einfach mal so zack
zack und machen hier so ein bisschen was
blaues rein so dass die Leute checken
okay hier ist irgendwas zu trinken drin
dann können wir beispielsweise hier
vorne noch so eine Untertasse hin malen
so dass die Leute checken ah guck mal
Brad jetzt direkt erraten mein Mann
Alter hier vorne die Untertasse malen
wir noch so ein bisschen zu Ende zack
dann können wir das ja auch noch so ein
bisschen schön ausfüllen so dass die
Leute das checken dass das hier ein
Becher ist ey sag mal seid ihr blöd
water Glas Wasser vielleicht zeichne ich
noch mal kurz einen roten Pfeil so dass
die Leute checken dass es um das hier
geht es ist ja ein Becher in welcher hat
aber manchmal auch andere Farben von
daher mache ich jetzt einfach mal grün
als Farbe kann aber auch theoretisch
eine ganz andere Farbe haben irgendwie
sowas und dunkelblau oder sonnenbrauen
dass die Leute checken es geht um das
hier ah guck mal hat Jojo hat ihr müsst
ja verstehen ich kriege ich auch mehr
Punkte dadurch wenn es Leute erraten
guck mal 485 habe ich jetzt nur Matilda
ist juicing the world hier oben sehen
wir eingeblendet dass das Wort relativ
viele Buchstaben enthält von daher bin
ich gespannt ob wir es erraten können
wenn Mathilda mal anfangen würde zu
zeichnen
muss man einmal auf den Tisch lang
geht's los was ist das was ist das ein
Schiff ein Schiff Schiff falsch Boot
falsch
Flagge nee
Piratenschiff nee
[Musik]
ich habe nichts mehr eingegeben auf
einmal Piratenschiff richtig aber kann
sein dass sie so Webseite irgendwie
gerade nicht richtig liegt der Boss und
Banger hier auf der Eins es ruckelt
krank
es ruckelt sehr sehr krank fällt mir
gerade auf ich meine achtet mal auf die
Uhrzeit hier oben das sind Sekunden da
steht jetzt gerade 73 und gleich springt
das dann wahrscheinlich wieder auf
irgendwie 60 Sekunden Komma 65 also wir
haben nur alle 8 Sekunden gerade ein
Bild weil ihr zu viel auf die Website
geht man es sollten acht Leute joinen
nicht 4000 wir haben ja auf jeden Fall
einen Typen mit verschiedenen Dingen er
hat hier irgendwie was und ein Pfeil da
drauf und das hat auch nur sieben
Buchstaben nee sogar nur sechs einer hat
schon Matilda hat schon ist das eine
Band nee ist das ein Lehrer mit H fängt
an Fabi hat auch schon hä hä
sag mal wer hat dir denn ins
gegengeschissen wo soll das denn Hockey
sein es läuft auf jeden Fall schon ein
bisschen flüssiger mittlerweile und das
seht ihr auch schon hier an der Uhrzeit
das ist mittlerweile normal abläuft von
daher können wir uns jetzt so ein
bisschen mehr darauf konzentrieren was
hier gezeichnet das ist eine Gießkanne
das ist eine ganz klare gießkannte zack
bring mir nämlich eine Gießkanne direkt
an Löwenzahn oh nur vier Buchstaben okay
Maus Hund oh das sieht das sieht ganz
komisch aus Bauch mann mann Mensch kein
Bauch okay er hat den Bauch
durchgestrichen dünn dünn dünn dünn dünn
vielleicht dünn ja
wir haben sage wieder die normal der
snoopy ist gerade dran mit zeichnen fünf
Buchstaben erdmalt eine Linie einen Ball
oder ist das ein Kopf guck mal wir
müssen jetzt ganz entspannt Vorgehen wir
müssen mal gucken das ist auf jeden Fall
die Sonne oder warte mal ist das schon
direkt die Sonne nee Sonne ist falsch er
versucht auch gerade weg zu radieren ey
das ist schlecht Komma da kriegt er
direkt einen Download raus mit dir
Snoopy was sind das für ein Schwachsinn
hier
[Musik]
erraten wie kann man das denn erraten
das ist der Abend oh mein Gott weil die
Sonne von so zu so untergeht und das
hier soll den Horizont darstellen Bruder
dann mal das mal doch eine Uhr
beispielsweise auch noch dazu jetzt ist
allerdings wieder Pablo Picasso
persönlicher ich mal einfach mal ein
Loch ganz entspannt haben wir hier eine
Ebene und danach
noch ein bisschen Rasen den können wir
hier hin malen guck mal Kevin secret
Freitag die haben alle direkt guck mal
wenn ich jetzt hier Fabi jetzt auch
direkt geraten guck mal wenn ich jetzt
hier beispielsweise in dem Livestream
wäre ne und die Leute könnten das Lesen
okay können Sie es lesen aber das ist
einfach nur gut gezeichnet von mir bin
ich ganz ehrlich noch ein Männchen hin
der hier rein läuft irgendwie so von
wegen und dann zack fällt darunter und
liegt dann plötzlich hier unten so drin
das ist ganz blöd und dann ist er
einfach traurig oh weil er in das Loch
gefallen ist Werder
besser kann man das doch nicht zeichnen
Matilda Tod ey schöner kannst du es
nicht zeichnen no joke schöner kannst du
ein Loch nicht malen immer mit der Ruhe
okay Matilda ist dran die schafft es
nicht mein Loch zu erraten ne guck mal
was macht die hier was ist das eine
Wiese die geht genauso vor wie ich
perfekt guck mal besser radieren ne guck
mal habe ich schon gedacht hier in
Mathea kriegt direkt einen Download
einfach weil du mein Loch gerade nicht
erraten hast blöde
Kuh Alter ist das heute noch was wird
alles gelöscht ich weiß noch nicht was
das da oben für ein Wort ergeben soll 20
Sekunden später ähm
ja
kann man Leute hier irgendwie mit
Scheiße bewerfen wie kann
da ist nichts wie kann secret Fighter
denn hier das Flutlicht wie kann secret
Fighter den flutlich erraten wenn da
nichts gezeichnet wird
[Musik]
ich schwöre euch ey ich soll das
beruflich machen
das eine dumme Aussage weil genau das
was ich gerade mache mache ich
berufliches wird am Start
ist das eine Ratte ey
wenn so Ratten aussehen würden ne mit so
langen Bein unserem kartoffelkörpern
boah nee da wird er mal raus aber Word
Tinte nee Füller vielleicht nee auch
nicht er malt jetzt gerade noch einen 39
39 der noch 39 Grad Thermometer nee
Wetter Wetter vielleicht nee
39 Grad was ist denn das ein Thermometer
das ist ein
Wort zwei Leute haben schon erraten nee
was ist denn das Fieber Fieber Apache
entschuldigung dass ich im Stich
gelassen habe ein Problem
und das ist ein Toaster das müsste ein
Toaster sein ne ist es nicht oh das ist
auf jeden Fall ein Küchengerät guck mal
das ist doch ein Toaster es ist braun
das hat da zwei Streifen oben so ein
Ding dran nee jetzt hat sie es komplett
weiß gemacht und jetzt wieder zurück hä
da ist auch ein Tee mit drin dass er gar
keinen Sinn keine Ahnung was das sein
soll
[Musik]
sind logisch war klar dass also ist ja
klar alles klar alles klar weiter geht's
mit Isabel hier etwas zeichnet das
könnte ein Feuerzeug sein nee es geht um
das was da oben drin ist ist das ein USB
Stick vielleicht was mit einem
Bindestrichen dann hätten ja wann
Bindestrich auch angezeigt äh
Fingernagel schreiben die anderen
Sprühflasche ist das ein Parfum
Deodorant
ey sorry dass ich das so sagt ne aber
ich bin einfach ein Genie ich bin dran
Curry machen wir mal so erstmal eine
Schale dass die Leute das checken zack
safe weiter schreibt Banane Banane Fabi
no joke Fabi lass mal ein saufen gehen
machen wir hier vorne erstmal einen
Tisch dass die Leute checken worum es
hier geht so malen wir eine Gabel kurz
und malen auch einen Löffel weil curry
ist man natürlich wie wir alle wissen
nicht mit einem Messer und dann machen
wir jetzt noch so ein paar Sachen rein
so ein rotes Stück irgendwie was dann
irgendwie Paprika sein könnte machen wir
noch so ein bisschen Grün rein hier hier
und was in dem Curry natürlich auch
nicht fehlen darf ist der Reis machen
wir hier so ein bisschen Reis hin und so
bzw könnten wir auch um die Leute nicht
zu verwirren daneben eine Schale machen
in der sich Reis befindet da kann man
dann einfach hier so zack zack zack zack
zack machen so ein bisschen Komma einer
hat es erraten das vielleicht soll ich
auch hier vielleicht noch eine Person
hin machen irgendwie so mäßig
dass sie halt checken okay das ist halt
zum Essen so das ist die Nase der Mund
und das
[Musik]
ich bin so gut ne das ist Patrick Star C
Sternen Sternschnuppe
[Musik]
was passiert denn
mich jetzt nicht
[Musik]
letzter weiches
und
laurice hat schon die Küche nee was ist
denn das ist das ein Topf vielleicht nee
es hat halt nur vier Buchstaben ist ein
Stuhl an dem Tisch im Garten da ist ein
er ich habe gar keinen Plan was das sein
soll Apache hat auch erraten oh run hat
es auch ey wenn Fabi das jetzt auch
gleich hat dann sind wir am Arsch ich
habe keine Ahnung was das sein soll vier
Buchstaben der dritte ist ein R
Büro
habe ich mich gerade mal so gerettet
Leute die letzte Runde
9.355 Luca auf der 1 Fabi komm geh weg
verpiss dich an der Stelle will ich das
heute wieder jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben Freunde wenn euch
Sketch voll mit der lucrew gefallen hat
dann lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch unter
diesem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos nichts verpassen ich
Strebe jetzt meine malerkarriere